apathy and frustration are on the rise
among voters in Quito ahead of Sunday's
wide-ranging referendum promoted by
embattled President Guillermo lasso to
address the country's deteriorating
social and economic conditions
we have no faith in politicians for all
the scandals that happened recently
people has lost trust in politics
[Music]
approval rating below 20 percent a
hostile Congress mounting government
corruption allegations and a dramatic
Rising gang-related crime conservative
president lasso has been left with
little space to maneuver
but the eight referendum questions which
cover security issues reducing the
number of lawmakers in Congress
Environmental Protection and the
possible extradition of ecuadorians
could help him regain initiative
popular consultations usually become a
referendum on the current Administration
but in this case despite the president's
major loss in political Capital the
referendum has strong support because it
addresses fundamental issues for the
people the critics argue that lasso is
hoping to use the referendum for a
personal political win a way to try to
boost support for his failing presidency
to the detriment of the country's
democracy
the former president of Ecuador's
constitutional assembly says the
reduction of assembly members will
reduce representation of remote areas
and strengthen the hand of the most
powerful parties
far from solving problems this
referendum could exacerbate some of them
it's like a poisonous Apple that shines
on the surface but if you read the
questions and annexes carefully you'll
see it won't solve neither security
issues or Democratic instability even
less the environment it's a tricky and
deceitful referendum unfortunately
it's a very good in June lasso barely
survived an impeachment vote after two
weeks of cost of living indigenous-led
protests that brought the country to a
halt
indigenous leader Leonidas Issa is
leading the no campaign he says the
government should instead comply with
the agreements that ended the
demonstrations
the government strategically avoids
implementing the agreement and comes up
with this referendum to confound things
all it really wants us to get some
oxygen to continue trying implementing
policies that have not worked until now
poles show the referendum results could
be very close and on Sunday ecuadorians
will all select more than 5 000 local
officials with the opposition expected
to gain seats across the country even
the passing of the referendum might end
up being a short-lived victory for lasso
Alessandro
al-jazeera Quito